do you know what the best selling
electronic of all time is well if you
guess the iPhone or the Samsung Galaxy
then you're probably right but that's
not all that surprising iPhones and
galaxies are basically ubiquitous around
the world having sold a billions of
units but something that might be
surprising is how many modest think pads
Lenovo has managed to sell over the
years Lenovo has sold a whopping 200
million thinkpads for perspective that
makes Lenovo the world's largest BC
maker by unit sales a title that they've
held on and off for decades and what
makes this achievement even more
impressive is that Lenovo breaks
basically every rule that you can think
of with the ThinkPad for starters the
think pad doesn't even look all that
impressive it's not the sleekest laptop
or the thinnest laptop like apple is
trying to create nor is it the bulkiest
and most Overkill laptop like Asus is
trying to create heck think pads still
have those red track points in the
middle of the keyboard as if we're
living in the early 2000s it's really
not all that controversial to say that
lovo hasn't changed the design all that
much since the ThinkPad was introduced
way back in
1993 yet none of this has stopped the
ThinkPad because while the ThinkPad
might not be the coolest laptop it does
exactly what it promises it's practical
functional reliable and offers
phenomenal value from a grounded
perspective these are exactly what any
consumer should be looking for but as
we've seen with the smartphone market
this doesn't always hold up in fact some
of the worst selling smartphones are the
most practical smartphones like the
Google pixel and HTC smartphones
meanwhile people tend to buy iPhones
year after year even if nothing changes
simply because the iPhone branding and
marketing are so powerful yet within the
laptop Market Lenovo has managed to rise
above all the hype and carve out a
massive segment for themselves in fact
in fact many would argue that if you
want all of the perks of a Macbook
without the Apple tags or apple antics
you get a ThinkPad so here's the story
of one of the last practical Electronics
that's still killing it in the year 2024
the Lenovo
ThinkPad taking a look back the story of
Lenovo takes us back to November 1st
1984 to a group of Chinese Engineers led
by Lu shanji and Danny Lou originally
the company was called Legend and the
team was focused on importing TVs but
after this effort fell flat Legend would
pivot to the rapidly growing PC market
but this wasn't all that easy either
Legend didn't exactly have the technical
knowhow or resources to bring a PC to
Market and scale production as such they
opted to fulfill background functions
within the market for example they
started off as a quality checker for
existing computer brands they would also
go on to create a circuit board that
allowed IBM compatible PCS to process
Chinese characters but while these
efforts were enough to run a small local
business Lou had a much bigger Ambitions
for legend and to even have a chance at
those bigger Ambitions Lou first had to
hire a much bigger and knowledgeable
team that could handle a task that was
as daunting as bringing a PC to Market
as such in May of 1988 Lou would pull
the trigger and place a job ad on the
front page of China youth news they only
had enough money to hire 16 people but
given the novelty of the PC industry
Legend would receive an unprecedented
number of applications 500 to be precise
for a non-name computer company doing
quality checks L decided to take
advantage of the interest and move
forward with as many applicants as
possible 280 would be given written
tests 120 would be interviewed in person
and 58 would be given offers even though
they could only afford 16 and before
they knew it they would end up with a
staff including 18 people with graduate
degrees 37 people with undergraduate
degrees and three students one of these
hires was a man named Yang Yong King who
would go on to be the CEO of Lenovo but
that was still a long ways away in the
meantime Legend had to figure out how to
support a Workforce they couldn't afford
this mainly consisted of taking on a
bunch of debt and living on scraps in
fact money was so tight that Lou and his
co-workers workers wouldn't even take
cheap public transportation opting to
walk everywhere but from lose
perspective this was all more than worth
it because he was spending all of this
money on engineering talent and R&D not
flashy Office Buildings or corporate
Retreats and that brings us into really
the key advantage of Lenovo unparalleled
efficiency Lenovo is able to run a
leaner and cheaper business than even
most of their Chinese counterparts and
when we're talking about an industry
such as PCS which has been largely
commoditized over the past few decades
this is critical in fact the average net
margin for computers and peripherals
currently stands at just
3.42% so coming out on top in this
Cutthroat Market is very much a test of
efficiency and grid an area in which
Lenovo has largely excelled in fact
Lenovo regularly boasts net margins that
are far Slimmer than even
3.42% they usually hover somewhere
around just
1.5% so if you've ever wondered how
Lenovo is able to offer such value
packed devices well there's your answer
all of the money you're spending is
directly going into just R&D and parts
virtually none of it is going into fancy
redesigns or advertising efforts in fact
even today Lenovo only spends $100
million per year on Advertising for
perspective Dell spends over 10 times
that every single year this tunnel
vision to focus of cutting costs
everywhere except for where it really
matters is what has allowed Lenovo to
launch such value packed computers which
brings us into the company's first
computer starting in 1990 Legend would
begin manufacturing and selling their
own computers one of their biggest hits
early on was the KT 8920 Mainframe
computer a lot of their models from the
1990s were rather tacky and had odd
quirks but back in the day people Loved
These quirks for example in their 1998
tan computer Legend included a physical
button whose entire purpose was to just
connect the computer to the internet and
open the default web browser obviously
such buttons seem rather out of place in
2024 but back in the 1990s people loved
it most of Legend's consumers were
first-time computer buyers and having a
dedicated button to access the internet
was extremely helpful in fact the TN
would go on to be the bestselling
computer in chinae history at the time
selling 1 million units in 2000 alone
such successes allowed Legend to call
out of the Dead hole from the late 80s
and even host a successful IPO but they
never forgot about their roots and what
actually made them successful as such
they would pour all of their profits
into improving production standards and
R&D which would eventually allow them to
launch their first laptop in
1996 by the end of the 1990s Legend
would become a household name
controlling 40 3% of the Chinese market
but outside of China Legend was a nobody
which brings us into the think pad at
this point most people wouldn't bad an
ey if you said that Lenovo created the
ThinkPad given that Lenovo and ThinkPad
have been synonymous for so long now but
the ThinkPad wasn't actually lenovo's
creation it was actually IBM's creation
shifting back to the early 1990s Toshiba
and compac had come out with portable
computers that they called notebooks and
IBM wanted a piece of the pie so they
would deploy their vast International
resources to create a competing notebook
that they would brand with their famous
slogan think IBM would go on to launch
the ThinkPad in October of 1992 and it
was a great capable portable computer
but it was by no means a sales driver
largely due to price the original
ThinkPad started at
$2,750 which is the same as $5,700 today
and it went up to $4,800 or $10,000
today as such the ThinkPad really only
appealed to businesses universities and
the government fun fact 1998 the
ThinkPad would become the first computer
to be certified for use on the ISS and
to this day it is still the only
computer that's allowed on the ISS but
aside from this fun fact the ThinkPad
didn't really have much else going for
it at the end of the day it was a niche
highly priced product that was
completely out of reach for the average
person but that's exactly how IBM liked
it it they didn't want to get into the
trenches and compete in a Cutthroat
Market they simply weren't all that good
at that in fact that's why they got
crushed in the PC market despite
pioneering the industry they simply
weren't able to keep up with cheaper
alternatives from Dell HP and compact
laptops however were a high margin
industry where they excelled wait never
mind that didn't last forever either by
the turn of the century laptops would
also become a highly competitive
industry with low margins and by the end
of 2004 IBM wanted to know part of it so
they would decide to sell ThinkPad to
one of their largest suppliers legend
for $175
billion from Legends perspective this
was their golden opportunity to make an
international name for themselves so
they wouldn't waste any time in
rebranding themselves as Lenovo and
kickstarting a whole new era for the
ThinkPad
lenovo's approach to ThinkPad was pretty
simple and straightforward the game plan
was to Simply apply lenovo's
unparalleled deficiency to the laptop
Market while also retaining all of the
best features of IBM for example Lenovo
very much adopted the transparency of
IBM now of course you could argue that
IBM isn't all that transparent to begin
with but for Chinese standards Lenovo
was making massive strides forward for
instance Lenovo adopted the American
Standard of releasing quarterly
Financial reports even though they were
only required to report twice a year
back home they also created committees
for Audits and compensation and Lenovo
would even go on to host the first
investor relations conference in
mainland China but not only did Lenovo
and press investors they would also
impress a lot of computer enthusiasts
who swear by the ThinkPad from their
perspective the ThinkPad was a
no-brainer you basically got a Workhorse
computer that used to be a status symbol
amongst business users for for an
affordable price thanks to Lenovo since
then the status of thinkpads have very
much worn off but the practicality
hasn't while the rest of the PC industry
has trended towards the Apple Way
producing computers that look Sleek but
are a nightmare to repair an upgrade
lovo has tucked to their tried and true
approach essentially producing a no
thrills Pro consumer MacBook now of
course this doesn't appeal to everyone
but for the people that it does appeal
to they would choose nothing else over
time Lenovo has tried to apply this
approach to other Industries like the
smartphone industry for example they
bought Motorola from Google for $2.9 one
billion in 2014 in an effort to break
into the smartphone market but Lenovo
would figure out the hard way that
smartphones are still very much a status
symbol and even someone like Google
isn't able to car out market share using
a practical phone but while smartphones
didn't work out in their favor Lenovo
has managed to find success in other no
thrill Industries like the server Market
in 2014 for example Lenovo purchased yet
another IBM business their server
business for 2.3 billion and today
Lenovo stands as the fourth largest
server maker in the world controlling
6.2% of the market all of this has
allowed Lenovo to grow to as much as $70
billion per year in revenue for a
perspective that makes them a top 200
company in terms of Revenue given their
meager profit margins though this
doesn't even translate to $1 billion
worth of profit today but hey is that
really something to complain about after
all that's what makes Lenovo the last
practical Electronics maker while Lenovo
has managed to maintain large demand in
the modern era the same cannot be said
about other practical Electronics makers
like Sony and Panasonic check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one